617 830 4750 is the number that is the
one and only number to call when we take
live calls let's start with your name
and where you're calling from hey David
my name is azim I'm a huge fan and
admirer of yours and you helped shape
many of my religious and political
opinions that and thanks for following
me on Twitter thank you my name is azim
my name is azim but I got that part so
what can we do for you Suzie oh oh sorry
sorry hard to say my name ok ok uh yeah
I sweis wanted to ask you um uh I've
been wanting to become more involved in
the political discourse but I found
destruction of politics namely mmm I
found it increasingly distressing and so
I'd like to know David you seem very
poised very composed very like very
thick-skinned I was wondering how do you
work through that distress yeah when you
know confronting you know very car you
know very conflicting very opinionated
you know political issues very you know
controversial issues well I I hate that
this is my answer but I think it kind of
is I think it's just desensitization I
don't know that it's any particular
skill other than just being exposed to
it and just realizing that there's
absolutely insane people who want
horrible things for the country in the
world and I can't change everybody's
mind these people are going to exist I
don't know that there's really any other
way I mean Rachel since you've been in
this less a shorter time than I have do
you find yourself more acutely
distressed with the people who seemingly
have no idea what's going on yet want
horrible horrible things politically or
do you have some method it's hard
because I feel like in the beginning you
become more aware of it because it's
more in your face and then as you as you
said I'm so elegantly who become
desensitized to it yeah I wish I had a
better you know I guess my advice would
be become involved and at first it's
going to be distressing when you hear
that people think for example it's a
great idea to have healthcare be
something bought and sold for profit
right that's
disturbing and distressing you'll get
used to it eventually and then uh you'll
you'll be jaded and uh you you'll move
beyond it that's the best possible
advice I can give you a schism I thank
you very much no problem really really
appreciate the tell thanks for the great
honor it's good to hear from schism
there gamefly is sort of like Netflix
for video games they have over 8,000 new
and classic games for xbox one xbox 360
ps4 ps3 wii and a bunch of other
platforms and you can play as many games
as you want for one monthly fee and if
you find some games you want to keep you
can buy them for a low use price there's
never any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
gamefly offer.com / tdps the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the david pakman show audience and
support our show by going to gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s